[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Alfred Eva Lucci mayor of
the city of Cambridge and the Honorable
Paul eat Tsongas chairman of the board
of regions of higher education of a
Commonwealth of Massachusetts and former
United States Senator from Massachusetts
mr. Tsongas will now give the address
[Applause]
thank you
before I begin I think we should pause
to remember the slain students in China
the authorities in China know full well
that history will record their brutality
they are prepared for that legacy what
they are not prepared for is that
history will also record their futility
in this era of the global village the
tide of democracy is running and it will
not cease not in China not in South
Africa and not in any corner of this
earth
with a simple idea of democracy and
freedom has taken root to students in
China our economies our sisters I say
that we are with you and we pray for
your deliverance
I would like to express my appreciation
for your kind invitation to speak to you
today but I must say I accepted it with
some hesitation 31 years ago I graduated
from high school I don't remember who
spoke to me at that event 27 years ago I
graduated from college I don't remember
who spoke to me then either and 22 years
ago I graduated from law school since
that was the sixties I didn't go to my
graduation so by definition of no idea
who spoke to me there either
I fear that I'm going to be the great
trivia question in your reunion
before I begin I would ask you to
indulge me in three acknowledgments
first I'd like to acknowledge my uncle
Alex Angus and my aunt Bertha alex is a
graduate of the class of 1928
my family is a classic American story of
the role of education my grandfather
came over here in 1910 the good news is
that he took his six children he sent my
father to Harvard my two uncles to MIT
in my three ons to Simmons that's the
good news the bad news that most of them
became Republicans but not Alex
I'd also like to acknowledge the fine
work done by dr. David Saxon in raising
for the first time the standard of
excellence in public higher education in
Massachusetts and finally I'd like to
acknowledge the work of dr. Paul gray
and the faculty at MIT in the recent
study on competitiveness which is just
the latest example of mi t--'s
contribution to vital thought in this
country at this point I would like to
give you a moment to applaud your
families who have supported you all
these years
[Applause]
they are here at your commencement to
share this moment your years at MIT have
bled in their hearts deep in their pride
and destroyed their pocketbooks
I have two thoughts that I would like to
leave with you today and perhaps I can
illustrate each with the story there was
a myth that's often perpetuated at
commencement that holds that only hope
and promise lie beyond the worlds of a
khadeem don't worry be happy everything
is fine that advice reminds me of the
story of a farmer is it an automobile
accident and he sue the other side for
damages well they came to trial the
attorney for the other side put the
farmer on the stand and said the time
the accident you said to the state
trooper I feel fine did you say that
Thomas said yes I did well the attorney
said then how can you possibly sue for
damages well the farmer said look I was
driving down the road in my pickup
I had the cow in the back of my truck
your client came across the center strip
hit me broadside and both I and my car
went flying to the side of the road very
badly hurt
the state trooper arrived on the scene
went up to my cow said this cows in
terrible shape
two cars revolver bang right between the
eyes he said to me how do you feel
everything out there is not fine a
commencement is the time of joy but it's
also a time of melancholy but then again
so is life when I look back at my
graduating class that remember co-equal
faces with co-equal hopes and co-equal
futures the co-ed quality soon ended in
life took over life with its oddities it
surprises it's uneven effects it's there
I said it's the law of averages the fact
is that your class as mine will
experience the same vagaries some of you
will live long lives some of you sadly
will die young some of you will achieve
great professional success some of you
will never live up to your promise some
of you will know in inner peace some of
you will be plagued by inner turmoil
some of you will truly give of
yourselves to those around you and some
of you will be consumed with self the
fact of this unevenness is merely part
of our earthly voyage what is intriguing
is that looking at you
no one can say who will do what or who
will be what when I graduated from
college if the speaker had announced
that one of us sitting there we'd be
elected to the United States Senate at
the age of 37 and come down with cancer
at the age of 42 I would have been
absolutely and totally certain that
neither event would happen to me and yet
both did
in a year reunion similar tales of
unlikelihood will be told
yeah it is this very unlikelihood that
cries out for stabilizing forces the
handles to grab on to
well they exist as well the same old
dull bromides you've heard about forever
hard work family community love of
others love of god's earth love of
moments that are rare and wonderful i
will not preach these values to you but
they are there just don't be surprised
when eventually you feel the same way
someday your life will end don't fear
your mentality because it is as very
mortality that gives meaning and depth
and poignancy to all the days that will
be granted to you my second message is
less personal and more collective no one
is immune from the larger events of his
or her time the depression World War two
civil rights Vietnam the spring of 1989
in China these events intrude upon our
lives and radically affect our
directions in my time it was the Kennedy
call to public service in the third
world had there been no Peace Corps my
life would have been radically different
recent times suggest the onslaught of
AIDS the unknowable effects of the
Islamic Revolution and the financial
risk of mega banks and debtor nations
locked into a true fatal attraction but
I believe the dominant factor in your
lives on a collective scale would be
economic my father's generation gave to
my generation a land of wealth and
purpose and world economic Domino
my generation has enjoyed this wonderful
power influence abroad comfort at home
ah the sweet pursuit of pleasure a BMW
in every yuppie garage a weekend snort
of cocaine cocaine by the pool America's
best and brightest flocking to Wall
Street to follow the gods of Ivan Boesky
and Michael Milligan money untold wealth
staggering wealth 500 million dollars in
one year and best of all there was none
of the grub enos of having to
manufacture things or to drill wells or
to lay down pipe or to install train
tracks this new wealth comes from
sitting in an office a wonderfully nice
office and playing with numbers the
magic words arbitrage hostile takeover
leveraged buyout sale of assets you
would have to be truly stupid to think
of inventing something or designing
something or creating something it's all
in the numbers man it's all in the
numbers but there are other numbers
forty years of increased consumption
falling savings rates lagging
productivity statistics high cost of
capital but most of all numbers numbers
written in red debt real debt crushing
debt the 1980s we have gone from being
the world's largest creditor nation to
the worst debtor nation the world has
ever known and all of this debt we give
to you our beloved children America is
on the verge of economic decline we are
now in an undeclared and unfelt and
unrecognized battle for our future
standard of living are we fighting
yes we are that's the good news
the bad news is that we are fighting the
wrong war we still pour our resources
into the Cold War the enemy is still the
Russian bear ladies and gentlemen the
cold war between the United States and
the Soviet Union is over
[Applause]
not because of anyone they are here
being conjul or gentler because of
economic realities these two aging boxes
with flabby midriffs losing their
economic muscle put simply they can't
afford the Cold War harsh economic
reality created by Mikhail Gorbachev not
an accident of history I'm not calling
for an abdication of our defense
responsibilities they remain I am
calling for a recognition of the brave
new world that exists it is time to deal
with the other war the war with our
friends the war with Japan and Germany
and Taiwan and Switzerland and Korea and
France sell to us and then take away our
patrimony in return can we turn our
attention away from the Kremlin and face
our new adversaries I think so I want to
believe that a mark is ready for it let
me illustrate this story that I'm going
to tell you was a true story when
Mikhail Gorbachev and Ronald Reagan were
negotiating the INF treaty they came to
a point of deadlock and the president
got up they turned to mr. Gorbachev with
all the others dealing he said I'm going
to tell a story about chairman Gorbachev
he said it's powder of perestroika he
called in the State Police and the KGB
and he said we lost we lose too many
people in highway fatalities in this
country I tell you there should be no
more speeding
if anybody speeds from here on in in
this country they should be arrested do
you understand
they said yes we do he said if you don't
arrest them it's your career so the
edict went forth a couple weeks later he
was at his retreat and overslept on a
Monday morning
remembered he had to be at the Kremlin
earlier so he and his chauffeur ran out
of the house as they were about to get
into the huge limousine he remembered
his edict he said move over I'll Drive
so out they went out the driveway down
the highway 95 miles an hour
and sure enough get pulled over by the
police in the police car there was a
veteran cop and a rookie cop the veteran
cop looked to the sides of the limousine
said to the rookie you go arrest who's
ever in that car so the rookie went over
had a long conversation finally came
back the veteran said did you arrest him
Ricky said no I did not veteran said why
not
the rookie said he was too important
Varian said well who was he the rookie
said I don't know but Gorbachev was his
driver
the relevance of that story if there is
any is that that story is the most tall
piece of political humor by United
States senators in America today in that
a story which is essentially probe
Gorbachev could be told and
Massachusetts in Utah tells you how far
we have come I think we're ready for
that change but the harder part is
taking on our friends taking on our
trading competitors we in America have
lost our edge we are zigging when we
should be zagging but we should be
producing we are consuming we are boring
we're not saving we have horizons
measured in quarterly reports not
ten-year plans we produced with the
casualness when the market demands
precision whistle while your work has
given away to take this job and shove it
the war that we talk about is not one of
Tanks of plains it is a war of
discipline a purpose of will of
determination of hard work of sacrifice
of attitude and above all education at
the core it is essentially a war of
cultures we have endured our tradition
of anti-intellectualism long enough let
us be done with it let us celebrate
intellect let us honour learning let us
pay homage to the Keen mind let us value
those who think we need to see and to
see clearly who our nation's Warriors
are in the 1990s and beyond there is no
need for Rambo a Conan the Barbarian
or Dirty Harry they are useless in this
war they are useless
our only weapons in this war of your
lifetime are the weapons of the mind in
this country we consider those weapons
to be curious at best unless we change
this part of our culture we will endure
a steadily declining American standard
of living in a nation more and more
owned by foreign interest you deserve
better we have not served you well we
have squandered a good part of our
collective patrimony perhaps here more
than almost any other campus in America
the products of MIT will be called upon
to restore that patrimony you must
become leaders in this cultural
realignment let me close with a story it
was a fellow from Massachusetts who went
to the Grand Canyon we don't have
anything quite like that in
Massachusetts except during the pothole
season and he was looking out at the
abyss and 5,000 feet straight down he
was so awed by it that he tripped and
over he went fortunately it was a tree
growing about 30 feet below the rim and
he grabbed that he was hanging there and
hanging there and finally in desperation
cried out is there anybody up there
finally after much silence a voice said
I am here I am the Lord the man said
well thank God you there God could you
help me Lord said well I would be
inclined to help you if you have faith
in me do you have faith in me they'll
say well of course I have faith in you
but can you hurry up God my fingers are
slipping so I said all right
I will help you to demonstrate your
faith
let go the man thought for a moment and
cried out is there anybody else up there
in this new war in a very real sense you
are what's up there you are pardon that
hard expression the best and the
brightest that you deserve it too even
applies mit speaks of great confidence
it can be a terrible burden if you let
it be but it is the great challenge of
your time and being a war in that
challenge should be wondrous I wish you
Godspeed for your sake for my sake and
for my children's sake thank you
[Applause]